ti bien je vous faire la ville interview
publiée dans cette émission c'est
l'interview de saïda attentions se
concentrent frédéric qu'elle et
l'insultent qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir
ah oui c'est donc c'est un interview
compliqué
on me traite souvent way de non écrivain
mondain ouais en fait ça fait plaisir
parce que c'est ce qu'on disait à proust
à cocteau ou à fitzgerald
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus dans la rue quelquefois il ya
des gens qui disent et canal+ je t'adore
michel comment tu t'appelles pour
quelles raisons seriez vous capable de
refuser votre plus belle histoire
d'amour frédéric j'ai pas si la fille de
montereau trop cher quels sont les
défauts
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour vous séduire j'ai pas
être aveugle
l'infoman à fait mal informé par des
notes inverse mais pas vraiment par qui
aimeriez-vous être détesté
alors bon il y en a déjà plein 1 mais
c'est vrai que j'aimerais bien être
détesté par norman mailer ou tom wolfe
qui soit fou de jalousie devant
l'évidence grand talent au bac
sauf qu'ils savent pas ils connaissent
même pas mon existence nous on connaît
merci c'est le journal il ya
interconnexion connaissais pas ça c'est
le magazine de la sexualité récréative
je vois depuis longtemps ça va tu le lis
mais pas dans le train fera vraiment
quel est le salaire comme n'avait pas
mérité
ah ben canal+ à partir de mon
licenciement en novembre 2002 eu un
parachute
voilà jusqu'en juin 2003 j'étais payé à
ne rien [ __ ]
ah oui c'est vrai convient donc c'était
c'était j'ai plus j'étais comprenant
leurs enfants parce que moi en euros du
genre 150 mille francs par mois
mais c'est bien par rapport à emmanuel
chain choquant c'est horrible je sais
j'ai honte de quelques lignes voudriez
vous qu'on vous accuse
c'est vrai qu'il est très très dur à
cette interview je tiens à dire festival
je sais pas ce que vous avez fait mine
tu l'auras casting du toit alors à un
crime de lèse majesté ch bien par quelle
maladie voudriez vous attire après quoi
un crime de lèse majesté de faire ça
quand il enchaîne sur la question voilà
voilà
par quelle maladie voudriez vous être
frappé par la modestie le priapisme oui
des blagues sexuelles ça marche toujours
nos intermarché sûrement fait la moyenne
c'est un mec bvk interdisez vous à vos
enfants que vous faites vous même du
skate
soit 34 je ne sais pas - la drogue
maintenant il faut préciser que ma fille
à 5 m et le talent que vous n'aimeriez
pas avoir frédéric je n'aimerais pas
voir j'ai pas le talent de marc lévy ou
christine orban
quel est le mauvais film que vous auriez
aimé créé par eric il le mobile que
j'aurais aimé écrire à part non non en
double zéro c'est très très bien merci
proscrit j'aime beaucoup et très drôles
j'adore jeu j'en parle d'autant mieux je
n'ai pas vu mais je pense que c'est très
bien c'est génial non un mauvais film
que j'aime écrire c'est on se calme et
on boit frais à saint tropez à frédéric
sens qu'elle est la dernière question
qu'il ne faut pas que je vous pose
j'ai pas mal je suis content parce que
pour l'instant vous ne m'avez pas
demander est ce que ça me faisait que
houellebecq soit parti chez flammarion
ça vous fait quoi que c'était sur un peu
sérieux ça fait mal au cul mais mal au
cul voilà
mais un jour il reviendra et je lui
dirai aux la pomponnette revient
bienvenus tu peux revenir qu'à voulu
voir du pays il voyait qu'il fallait pas
de la peur
le vent
m
le vent mauvais
je vais libérer eric et ramzy